so I'm David and I'm a co-founder and
the chief marketing officer of Soylent
and what I want to talk to you about
today is how sticking to your principles
and embracing the weird aspects of your
business can ultimately generate
interest in the form of press community
and ultimately sales so if for those of
you who aren't familiar with Soylent as
Sam mentioned it is something that can
sometimes be hard to describe what we do
is we make engineered staple foods so
those products that we make currently
are powder and a ready to drink meal in
a bottle and so the breakdown of they're
ready to drink for instance which we're
actually serving out here today is 400
calories and that's 20% of everything
that you need in a day that's carbs fat
protein fiber vitamins minerals
everything and so that is four so five
bottles of RTD would equal a 2,000
calorie perfect diet according to the
Institute of Medicine and the FDA and so
a lot of people consume Soylent for
breakfast for lunch dinner I consumer
for breakfast and lunch on the weekdays
I'm about sort of a 50% Soylent diet the
percentage of Soylent that someone
consumes in their diet is is often sort
of a subject of discussion and so we'll
get to that a little bit so how do we
get started that's me a couple years ago
when I didn't know any better
essentially I moved into a hacker house
with a couple guys in Sunnyvale
California in 2012 and we were looking
around and trying to figure out sort of
how we could cut our costs our rent was
as cheap as it could possibly be the
house was falling apart at the seams we
had to wash our dishes with the hose
the the only good thing about the house
actually was it had a pretty decently
sized pool in the backyard and so we
thought okay well this will be nice we
can invite people over we can have some
pool parties
you know maybe barbecue the the snag
there was that the pool was covered in a
thick layer of green algae and try as we
might we could not get rid of it we
would pour chlorine it would evaporate
the algae would come back and so that
was pretty frustrating but more
distressing than that was the fact that
we were essentially starving
especially from a malnutrition
standpoint so we would go to Costco and
we get corndogs ramen frozen pizzas as
you can see there and we just were not
feeling too good
you know we'd we'd go and we'd spend
hundreds of dollars at Costco and just
go through all of that food in just a
week and you know we'd be left feeling
pretty sick and so quite a few times you
know we'd be sort of lamenting our
misfortune and sitting in our backyard
eating a frozen Costco corndog looking
at the green pool thinking why can't we
kill this but you know more you
know again more important than the pool
was we were hungry and so we needed a
hero
enter Rob Reinhart our CEO he saw our
problem and he went about devising a
very ingenious solution which was a
scientifically engineered powdered food
right and as you can see that's Rob
looking very svelte with one of the
original glasses of Soylent that he made
and next room you can see some of the
original ingredients the different
powders that we mixed together to create
that original recipe and of course a
scale that would be out of place
anywhere except for a chemistry lab or a
drug den so
what we did is Rob lived on that
original recipe for 30 days and that
generated a ton of interest and so what
happened was we received an outpouring
of requests over 30,000 people wanted to
repeat the experiment where Rob lived
entirely on Soylent for 30 days and they
they offered to give their blood and and
do it under the supervision of a
physician the same way that Rob did and
so we thought to ourselves if 30,000
people are willing to give you their
blood you probably have a business and
so what we did is we looked around and
realized to produce Soylent it's scale
we needed to be able to afford a large
scale manufacturing contract and so to
put the money together necessary to
reach that scale we turned to
crowdfunding and ultimately we went down
to LA and we filmed a crowdfunding video
and we worked with a company called tilt
and we we launched our crowdfunding
campaign trying to break a hundred
thousand dollars to get that minimum
order quantity and we're fortunate
enough that within an hour we broke
through our goal and ultimately went on
to be the largest food crowdfunding
campaign of all time raising in excess
of three million dollars which was was
really awesome so today we are
headquartered in downtown Los Angeles
and we have over 50 employees we've
served over 20 million meals to date
we've grown about 300 percent year over
year since shipping and you know as you
can see from this shot of our office we
have you know people and large computers
and high ceilings which I'm told are all
indicative of success whoa okay there we
go so
essentially what I wanted to talk about
today is acting against conventional
wisdom and violating some of these sort
of cultural norms can be very important
to generating interest in your business
and so a lot of people you know it would
be anxious about sort of communicating
how to consume a powdered food or maybe
you should consume a powdered food and
we were but ultimately we really had no
choice so we had to realize that our
solution was a little bit weird and we
had to stick to our principles and and
so we went about trying to solve this
problem what to eat and so we had this
unusual product and so again we were
anxious about it we were trying to
figure out how do we communicate this
message most effectively so that makes
people comfortable so that they'll
understand that this is really a very
viable solution to eating when you're
hungry so initially we got some reaction
that was what we fear apparently some
people can't be bothered with food
Soylent raises 1 million dollars reminds
us what's wrong with Silicon Valley I
what's wrong with Silicon Valley Rob
Reinhardt holes no eating diet probably
isn't such a good idea I'll let you read
that caption on that photo for yourself
so ultimately we realize we're gonna
have our work cut out for us if we were
gonna try to communicate how normal and
really soothing our solution was so we
decided we had to embrace the weird
right
there are just inherently weird things
about our business that we shouldn't try
to hide behind we can't hide behind even
if we want to so instead of trying to
sort of make excuses we'll just go the
extra mile so I don't know what what
could we think about that might sort of
communicate the idea of a fictional
foodstuff that is everything that the
body needs and really great for survival
so an allusion to a 1960s science
fiction novel by Harry Harrison called
make room make room which was ultimately
adapted into a movie called Soylent
Green Soylent Green is a fictional
foodstuff that has everything that the
body needs to be healthy it also happens
to have a secret ingredient that some
people find distasteful no pun intended
which is humans right so as you can see
the reaction when naming this product is
is pretty strong a lot of people will
seem to remember one of the adaptations
of this sci-fi story in which the secret
ingredient of people is you know is very
sort of memorable so ultimately you know
this joke never gets old right and so
every post that we put on Facebook every
ad that we put out was very polarizing
right because of the sort of the harsh
sort of nature of the name and sort of
what it made some people think about but
ultimately it drove a ton of engagement
right you know the the number of
comments that we have on every post
every ad every time sort of someone who
hasn't heard of us sees us for the first
time it drives us engagement it drives
this interest that ultimately is very
valuable and drives a lot of impressions
that we might not normally get otherwise
you know these comments my marketing
teams favorite comments I think one of
them is why didn't they Google this fire
the marketing team fire the marketing
team haters so there's this old saying
in advertising you know basically the
concept is you know if you're trying to
sell glue and all else fails glue a car
to a wall so that's essentially what Rob
did when he lived on Soylent for 30 days
right he did this stress test this if I
can live on this for 30 days then
certainly I can use this to replace a
meal or a series of meals or replace
meals for several days in a row and so
this was an extremely compelling and
very important part of our start and
something that ultimately drove tons and
tons of engagement and and and it was
just essentially invaluable and so and
so he blogged about his experience as
well and further drove home violating
these cultural norms around food and and
how
people saw food so you know saying
things in you know new blog posting
interviews like I don't understand why
people want to eat as if they were cave
in we have super computers in one hand
and then we're shoveling leaves into our
mouth with the other right and that is
you know a little bit strange in
contradictory and so the idea of why
can't a food like every other problem be
reduced into its constituent parts and
so the idea that you know an apple is
more than the sum of its ingredients is
is something that you know we we wanted
to challenge so along those lines so
along those lines you know we used
scientific principles to design our
formula and design our ingredients and
what we ultimately wanted to do was to
use the best tools for the job and so to
us we're ingredient agnostic I don't
care if we get our protein from whey or
soy or rice what matters is the amino
acid profile and the amino acid ratio
the source is less relevant so you know
in the case of something like GMOs this
is very unusual again right because it's
contradictory from what a lot of other
food companies do if you walk into a
Whole Foods now you see vegan natural
organic non-gmo and really you know what
what our belief is that consumers have
been taught because in the past food
companies have been dishonest
historically and consumers have been
taught that these labels are proxies for
good health so if I see something that
says natural I can be confident that
it's healthy but things like hemlock are
natural and that doesn't always end up
so great you know when you consume that
substance so things like GMOs are very
very important for the future of
Agriculture and there's an entire debate
around them which is too long to get
into right now but our corporate stance
is that we're very Pro and by taking out
billboards and not trying to sort of get
away with anything being there
straight forward and open about our
preference that was something that also
generated more interest again another
thing being transparent about our
formula people say don't tell people
what's in your food product they'll copy
you well that's fine people did copy us
and we also engaged with and created a
community around making Soylent and
making their own Soylent and so this was
very very powerful for us because they
drove a lot of traffic to our forums and
our subreddit and helped create a
conversation and convert more people to
our banner of thinking and and again
ultimately was was very very good in
terms of driving traffic and ultimately
sales right then we sold food
exclusively online only e-commerce at
the time a little bit uncommon and
something that people said you know
you're a food product you need to go
into stores that's the only way that
people will buy you but you know from
our perspective we wanted to be passing
on as much value to our consumers as
possible and because of all the
financial implications involved in being
in a store it wouldn't allow us to
charge the affordable price that we
would like to charge you know as we
scale and and and make sure that we're
actually passing on as much value to our
consumers as we'd like and ultimately
again this was a good decision because
it enabled us to generate cash flow to
continue to scale and invest in R&D
which I'll get to in a second our
marketing some food products want to
tell you that they will make you
superhuman I will not promise you that I
will tell you that if you drink Soylent
you'll be healthy and you'll be able to
get more things done and so that is a
message that is very much resonated with
our consumers and something that you
know ironically I think by keeping your
clothes on you can generate more
attention sometimes iterating our
product like software we had a lot of
ideas about where we wanted to take our
product and what the ideal vision of our
sort of end product would be but we had
a crowdfunding campaign we had customers
waiting and we couldn't iterate and make
it perfect and so in software this is
very common right you you release
versions but in food a little bit less
common and so we put out our first
version so we lent 1.0
that had an oil bottle associated with
it and and that's because saturated fats
as many of you likely know are solid
often in room temperature and so if you
want a high monounsaturated fat profile
then often you know you need to resolve
to consume liquid fat ultimately by
Soylent 1.4 we were able to work out a
deal with a supplier to generate a
custom starch micro encapsulated fat
blend that enabled us to throw away the
oil bottle and keep everything in one
pouch much more convenient ultimately we
got to the ready to drink again we have
samples here so then just high level as
you can see the more unusual things that
we did not by being deliberately unusual
but by sticking to our principles and
understanding that we could go one way
or the other and we might as well
embrace our weirdness enabled us to
generate a lot of interest and drive
press and drive our community and again
ultimately drive sales quick word about
our reddit community so a reddit
community is a fine example of all of
the sort of different communities and
that we have in the reddit community
actually receives more hits per month
than our website sometimes and so that's
an extremely powerful resource that we
have and we look to them for ideas and
we are able to engage directly with our
customers and because we have such a
vibrant community it's really been been
quite beneficial to us you know in a
number of ways throughout the history of
our business so okay sorry there we go
so a quick word about being unusual and
being weird so it's not all rainbows and
butterflies sometimes some really
frustrating things happen so that's
stress test that I mentioned earlier
really really effective for us as a
business really important one of the
most important things that we did right
stress testing showing that our product
could stand up to a very high-pressure
situation generated a lot of interest
but then people were so interested they
continued to replicate it and take it
further and further and
so people wanted to live on Soylent for
30 days and recreate that experiment and
journalists wanted to do it and it was a
very interesting thing and people were
we're very interested in it and and we
think that's great the products designed
for that why not however that led to a
mistaken assumption that we're still
combating a little bit today with regard
to what Soylent is used for some people
still regard Soylent is something that
i'm on Soylent all I consume is Soylent
I don't understand why someone would
want to live that kind of lifestyle when
of course Soylent is a tool that you can
use as needed for you so of course if
you can live for 30 days you can
certainly use it for breakfast so that's
you know that's just something to be
aware of with some of these sort of
tactics but ultimately you know we don't
really regret anything as far as being a
little bit weird being a little bit
unusual and challenging some of these
cultural norms so I just want to
reiterate that I think it's better to
disagree with conventional wisdom if you
know that you're right ultimately you'd
be surprised how it can actually benefit
you so as far as what's next for Soylent
we released 2.0 last fall again we have
samples here so if you didn't eat
breakfast
there's no excuse after this to go grab
a Soylent you'll thank me later trust me
and with regard to the far farther
future this is an example of an
industrial fermentation tank so 30%
roughly of Soylent 2.0 as calories come
from algal fat so that is lipid oil or
oil that's extracted from algae in a
tank such as this this is sort of a
pilot
so think about like a brewery that has a
tank full of algae and then you French
press it and you take all of the really
healthy very clean very efficiently made
fats and then you can put it into food
products such as ours so we strongly
believe that the future of ingredient
production is through microbial
engineering so ingredient production
through microbes and so instead of
two-dimensional farmland you really have
these three
tanks that can grow in warehouses that
you can stamp all over the world and
that's something that we're really
focusing a lot of our time and effort
and our D spend on so again we want to
provide nutrition to the world and so we
are not afraid to be a little bit weird
and leverage the power of science to
make sure that we can accomplish that
and make sure that everybody has enough
to eat thank you very much all right two
quick things so just kind of as the day
moves forward this is we're gonna be
doing a QA so if you guys do have a
question just kind of work your way down
we have time for about two here second
thing if anybody needs a business idea
make better clickers sorry about that
David but I actually have a question
myself so you know obviously we had
somebody live off Soylent for 30 days
you guys did it as well I know we had
our guy do a blood test before and after
what would like someone's blood test
look like after living off your product
for 30 days just kind of curious well
ideally they shouldn't deviate at all
from the norm and so you know what we
really like to see in sort of a win case
but that's sort of when the deck is
stacked in our favor is someone has
metrics sort of outside the healthy
range and then after the Soylent diet
they're within it and so you know I
think it's one of these things where no
news is good news in that case thanks
for your presentation you described
briefly the crowdsourcing that you did
would you be able to elaborate on why it
was so six why you think it was so
successful and characteristics of it
that you would recommend to include or
not include during that process sure
yeah I think with regard to crowdfunding
I think you know some of these I think
are well catalogued and at this point
and so I'm not sure if I'm doing it
justice but for us you know things like
ensuring that we had press interest
before launching the campaign you know
making sure that our PR and our
relationship with some key reporters was
good having a community who was already
interested in the product that was able
to help us see that campaign
working with a great partner like tilt
that took a special interest in helping
us succeed I think we're sort of the the
critical factors there I'm curious if
you guys looked at spirulina as a
protein source what do you think of that
and also maybe some non-essential
elements like boron nutrition especially
performance-enhancing sure yeah I think
that's a great point so okay so first
question spirulina super interesting
definitely has a lot of potential with
regard to incorporation but one of the
things that we really have to consider
is taste and texture and also of course
if we're talking about spirulina either
it depends what nutrient soom you're
talking about protein and so the the
protein extraction process at this point
hasn't reached industrial scale and
isn't very cost effective something that
we could potentially be interested in in
driving towards ourselves with regard to
things like boron other sort of
quote-unquote non-essential things I
think that you know it with regard to
these products that we have out on the
market right now our value prop is
really to provide everything that's
essential and so with regard to some of
these non essentials it's definitely
something that we're interested in but
with regard to something that we sort of
have to have in our product it's not
something that is super critical for us
right now sure that's all the time we
have for questions thank you David yep
you